hello freak [ __ ] wait and then I
looked at the audience and it was like
whoo and I had to breathe a little
through my nose but what do we do on
stage are we breathing through our nose
or are we breathing through our mouths
we [ __ ] talk [ __ ] for 45 to an hour I
looked at the special I shot him like
where am i breathing yeah how
interesting that we gotta watch that
next time yeah yeah that's what we doing
up there yeah
you're not thinking just breathing yeah
well you just concentrated so much on
what you're trying to say that it all
just comes natural just like right now
like while I'm talking to you right now
there's like I took a little breath
right there but I wasn't thinking about
it I just want any I only need a little
bit of air right you know because it's
so natural for you yeah maybe take me in
a conference the first time and I'm
gonna be shaking and go yeah run into my
world and then yeah right you see that
from people that are giving speeches you
do see that when the lists have not
become comfortable public speaking
public speaking is one of the most
stressful things for people for some
people like number two or number one in
some people's world like it's really
yeah yeah I had one one time a judge
asked me he was about to sentence me and
he goes do you have anything to say to
use for yourself and I had it written
down
I had everything Joe Rogan I started
tweaking he's like don't worry about it
yeah man I couldn't talk I went right
into a panic when this little man looked
at me but people get nervous you know
and when you get nervous your adrenaline
kicks in and when your adrenaline kicks
in everything tight better you know just
you know and physiological stress like
yoga positions can kind of mimic that
you know like when you are in a position
like when you've got your hands over
your head and you're leaning your whole
body to the side it's very hard to stay
smooth with your breathing when you're
in those spots like that's the number
one thing with our concentrate on
holding my body in that position is not
nearly as hard as holding my body and
breathing smoothly breathing smoothly is
the most difficult part of that that
posture like a lot of postures and the
students have changed of breathing you
start to changing inside and me changing
outside yeah
yes I see as she did is happening a lot
you know a lot what is the first
reaction when you're under stress
tension tension but for if you look it
back the what happened when you were in
the Pretoria pretty story prehistory in
greatest anything about it you you are a
prey what you're doing unlike any animal
like a cat in the road in the road they
start to pompous is hell so you bring a
bigger right right that's what we're
doing we've grown our shape so the
present might look like that's like oh
we're too big I'm gonna attack a simple
simple prayer we try to you know our our
skin started trickling something like
with your nice pumps we air we don't
have hair but we start to do the same in
either sense that was goosebumps arm
it's like your hair spammed and I'm just
make you live figure and why that's
interesting and if I look it how come
it's like that when you hear a good song
that's it infantry like your headless
prom you're like it's like a lot of
people the mission trip a date or the
old thinking okay we go tactical
training with all these and we can
control fear reaction not two different
things you can control when you are
really under stress for Delta the kind
of situation so our rate fears and other
things matter of fact under eye
intensity workout you become your rat
under fear you become important so it's
different different physiological things
going into you into your body so the
only things the people differently so
understanding that doing some kind of
under an intensity workout we can
control also the fear real fear because
real fears and other things you know
it's one of the things you see with
fighters is they perform better when
they're more active when they fight more
often so if a fighter fights like three
times a year they're used to fighting
every few months and they get that that
feeling of competition becomes a normal
natural thing for them and it's also
something that happens when you see a
fighter lose when you see a fighter
losing they come back they are very
tense and they fight a lot of times they
fight different because they're they're
now worried and concerned about the
consequences of failure and you see that
that fear that tension it's in their
system and then their whole their whole
way mode of operating as
as an athlete changes because of that
tension there's been a recover for this
shot
for the new duration they've been
through sure and that's also one of the
biggest factors when you talk about the
difference between the way someone
performs in the gym versus the way
someone performs in competition we've
all known these guys that were
phenomenal in the gym but for whatever
reason they weren't able to win in
competition it's so common it's with
some guys it's almost like like it's
crazy it's almost like there's a spell
on them or something like you'll see
them in the gym you like this guy's a
world beater but they can't beat anybody
in a competition why is psychological
it's all psychological there they are
imprisoned by their own fears and doubts
they don't have the confidence to rise
to the occasion they don't have the
confidence to perform under pressure
they don't have they can't just accept
the potential failure they can't they're
so overwhelmed and imprisoned by their
fear of failure that when they get out
there they can't perform at their best
what's crazy because it forces failure
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
because they can't perform like they do
in the gym they can't just react they
can't flow like when you are fighting
when you're at your best you're sort of
just in this empty space like you're not
you're not thinking about the moves as
much as they're just happening and
you're just relying on your training and
you're almost be the best thing you do
is stay calm because as soon as you get
emotional as soon as you get aggressive
you might win being emotional degress if
you could catch someone and knock them
out but you also go might get knocked
out yourself
you might do something that's not smart
like when you're talking earlier about
playing chess martial arts is a lot of
ways like very much like chess but way
more complicated because your physical
consequences are so severe so there's
always fear it's not just about losing
it's about getting hit and that
punishment of physical consequences is
just so significant it's so much
different even than in jiu-jitsu like
jiu-jitsu the physical consequences are
tapping and losing and those are
terrible but it's nothing like getting
kicked in the face or getting one of
those Yoel Romero flying knees your head
you know that kind of fear is that's an
overwhelming fear and for some people
they diggity throw up when they're in
the locker room and they
they panicked me they get so scared they
just can't perform under pressure you
know you know it's um if you transfer
these officers to some of the operator
you know they some of the parade too did
literally dump when you say an operator
you're talking to us for a special
soldiers Special Ops guys this is the
tough no they dealt super guys you know
yeah right
you know I'm amazed by those guys no I
just chapeau no but it's natural you
know they say you know maybe enduring
the task might be [ __ ] my pants you
know but physiological it's pure
geologic oh and then then you keep going
then you keep it just keep going oh [ __ ]
now because that's the physiological
reaction to death you have stress factor
oh yeah your body want to get lighter to
fight back faster or run away or else
you can't control you know is nothing to
be shame about it you see with animals
as well I mean that's the famous video
these two bears fighting and as the
Bears are fighting the rock they're
[ __ ] all over the place as they're
fighting they're [ __ ] I I love
watching movies like collateral or
something like people go into someplace
and they should have place up and
people's reaction how they run that's
not usually the case bro I've seen it
people drop to the [ __ ] floor people
drop without even getting shot I don't
know what you just freeze yeah the
sounds of video you being somewhere and
being transferred to the sound of
gunfire
it's [ __ ] overwhelming and some
people get it and react to it and some
people just think it's the fourth of
July yeah you know it's really weird but
I've seen people [ __ ] drop from fear
and drop from fear something that I was
as a child I was two blocks away from
just people dropping from fear you know
it's so like I mean I when I lived at
Aspen to have the ESI bodyguard Academy
and aspect yeah wonder sir I don't know
but the guy supposedly was in a room 6
by 12 room when he killed 12 Mexicans at
night point with his band so he opens up
this ESI thing and it's you know it's 20
G's you know it's a summer long program
and you learn how to adjust up at the
high altitude and drive an evasive
driving and shooting
then they have a course on maritime how
to defend people out on the ocean and
all that stuff but she Aspen it all that
was those places like Woody Creek where
you went is home to the baddest retired
soldiers in the world and you don't know
who they are
you just think that dude over there with
the American flag is mowing the lawn
that guy killed 80 people one end and be
hey guys there's a guy never die no I'm
telling it I'm Mallory Owens where they
put them why why they're coming back
because the mountains to keep him away
from civilization chanting in Chinese
music somewhere they don't ever want
that to happen
great glass in case of war and there was
a guy that came in that was a Marine
that bro Joe you know anybody comes in
with stories I know one thing when I see
it I believe it the [ __ ] used to
get picked up at Aspen Airport in the
helicopter yeah like they said like a
helicopter with two guys jumping out
four guys around them and he was just
waving but uncle Joey I was 19 now and
he would tell me stories about you know
that the Green Berets and all these guys
was sitting around saying cooking chili
and they were all telling how many
people they killed I killed 18 I killed
22 meanwhile he was staring the soup
with his dick over the fire and I'm
saying like that's the type of stories
this guy would tell he had me all [ __ ]
up in the head and I asked him once I go
should I go to that ESI and he goes
listen I go in there and smack them all
with my left hand he goes first of all
you can't teach what you need to learn
over there over there because four years
of Charlie and the bush is a lot better
than 12 weeks of you hanging out with
some white dudes with suits shooting
people targets in the mud it's not real
it's not until there's real consequences
so that's why he said it just wasn't
don't you think though it's better than
nothing I would think that it's better
than nothing I would think that the best
thing would be actually being in boot
camp actually going to buds actually
being in some sort of a situation we
realized this is life this is real
whereas if you're if you're preparing
like up in Colorado and you're just
going through that cord right now you
might have some things in your mind
but that's one of the things like people
say to me like like sure I take a
self-defense class like well they show
you how to kick somebody in the knee I
go listen to me that [ __ ] is not gonna
like there was there's a guy on the
[ __ ] radio that was he was always
talking about it was on an Opie and
Anthony show back in the day and as I
was talking about this difference
between the street and martial arts
martial arts tournaments does know
there's rules in the street there's no
rules and I'm like I [ __ ] hate when
people say that kind of [ __ ] because
listen to me the stuff that works on
trained killers is the real [ __ ] and if
you think that you're going to come in
and you're going to throw some [ __ ]
karate chop at someone's balls and
you're going to somehow or another be
able to stop Anderson Silva from kicking
you across the room you're out of your
[ __ ] mind you're out of your mind you
personally you're not going to karate
chop his balls he's not going to let you
get close enough to him and if he does
let you get close enough to him he's
going to strangle you and you're not
gonna be able to do a goddamn thing
about you're going to be a hundred
percent helpless so this these ideas
this is a shortcut and the shortcut is
like street defense it is this a certain
pressure points around your neck I could
attack that and you will be helpless no
no no you're not going to get my neck
you [ __ ] let me grab your friend gun
yeah there was a guy the store used to
pinch down on literally that this is the
biggest phony I've ever met in all my
years of meeting phony martial arts
guards he's to pinch down on your
thumbnail she's like there's a pressure
pointing at father like [ __ ]
dude lie on me with their knee on my
neck like they'll put all their weight
on your neck to try to get you to give
up the armbar like if you're in a
situation where you're defending it's an
armbar and the guys on top you guys will
put their [ __ ] knee at or and thirty
pound male put his knee on your neck
always trying to and it'll put all his
weight on it and you're not your guns
not happen from that you think I'm gonna
tap for my thumbnail it's funny I saw
people try to get in today special
potion community I try to teach them
pressure point a [ __ ] oh you realize
this guys wearing bulletproof jacket
yeah you know best if you look at them
doing all the material you're not gonna
even access to the body yeah good what's
so crazy crazy there's so many stupid
martial arts courses with so it's so
[ __ ] dumb it's so dumb there's so
many these
ridiculous ideas that you're going to be
able to defend yourself with some tricks
[Applause]
[Music]